hi this is Mario with Mario's math
tutoring coming to another math video to
help you boost your score in your math
class improve your understanding and
hopefully make learning math a lot less
stressful so in this video what we're
going to talk about is how to eliminate
the parameter when you're working with
parametric equations so you probably
already know from your math class that
parametric equations are usually
composed of you know two parts and you
can see this is like the horizontal
component the X component as a function
of T usually we think of T as time and
then over here we have Y which is like
the vertical component and that Y value
is a function of time as well
but what we want to do is we want to
eliminate that parameter T and just get
an equation in terms of x and y so let's
see if we can do that so in this example
what we're gonna do is we're going to
solve for T in that top equation so
we're gonna do that by getting T by
itself so X minus 1 subtract the 1
equals 2t we're gonna divide by 2 ok so
that now we have T equals X minus 1 over
2 now if we put that in for T in the
second equation we get y equals 4 times
X minus 1 over 2 and you can see the 4
and the 2 are going to cross reduce and
then we can distribute the 2 into the
parentheses so we get y equals 2x minus
2 so now we have an equation just in
terms of X's and Y's if we want to graph
it what you can do is of course we can
graph this just as a slope intercept
form of a line the slope is going to be
2 and the y-intercept is negative 2 so
we're going up 2 over 1 up 2 over 1 and
there is our line right there but the
other component of this that you want to
pay attention to is the direction so are
we going this way s T increases or are
we going this way as T increases and
what you can do is just make a quick
table okay like this and you can just
say all right when T is 0 what are the X
and y coordinates so if I put 0 in for T
here you can see I'm getting x equals 1
and if I put 0 in for T here you can see
I'm getting 0 okay and then if I put T
equals 1 that's 2 plus 1 which is 3 and
if I put 1 here I'm
for so you can see we're going as Tia's
getting larger and larger as it's
increasing
we're going from one zero okay over two
three four so that means that we're
going in this direction and we can just
indicate that with these little arrows
along the the line there so with
increasing values of T we're going that
direction along the line okay now the
second example we're gonna look at this
one here x equals four cosine theta plus
3y equals nine sine theta minus two now
just a quick reminder remember the
Pythagorean trig identities remember
this one here cosine squared theta plus
sine squared theta equals one well if
you do okay we're going to use this okay
to again eliminate that parameter in
this case our parameter is Theta
okay the angle theta and the way we're
going to do that is we're gonna solve
for cosine and we're gonna solve for
sine so what I mean by that is we're
gonna get the cosine by itself so in
this top equation we're going to
subtract three and divide by four so we
get cosine theta equals X minus three
divided by four same thing this bottom
equation we're going to get the sine by
itself so we're going to add two and
divide by nine so we get sine of theta
equals y plus two all divided by nine so
now what we can do is we can substitute
in place of cosine theta X minus three
divided by four the quantity squared
because this is cosine squared plus y
plus two divided by nine squared since
that's the sine of theta and that equals
one now if we take it up just one step
further simplify it a little bit more we
get X minus three squared over sixteen
plus y plus two squared over 9 squared
of course which is 81 equals one in case
they're with me so far so this is the
form of what type of a equation an
ellipse right so if we want to graph
this ellipse you can see it's centered
at 3 negative 2 1 2 3 negative 2 okay
we're going for the square root of 16 4
in the x-direction
one two three four okay right there four
in the other direction okay and then the
y direction we're going up nine and down
nine a square root of 81 so that's two
three four five six seven eight nine
right about there and then one two three
four five six seven eight nine right
about there and then there's our ellipse
right like that okay now the only thing
left for us to figure out is the
direction are we going you know
counterclockwise are we going clockwise
and again what I would do is I'd make a
little table like this okay so I'd say
here's theta here's x and y so theta is
zero radians okay that would be what
that would be cosine of zero is one
times four is four plus three is seven
so we're here at seven sine of zero
though is zero times nine is zero minus
two is negative two so we're starting
over here at seven negative two
somewhere down around here okay and then
if let's say let's say this is ninety
degrees or PI over two
okay well cosine of 90 degrees is going
to be what it's going to be 0 times 4 is
0 plus 3 is 3 sine of 90 degrees is 1
times 9 is 9 minus 2 is 7 so you can
super moving from okay now this is 3/7
up here approximately so with increasing
okay values of theta is that theta is
getting larger and larger we're moving
from this point to this point and that
tells us that we're going to be moving
in this direction around the ellipse
okay all right so I hope this video
helps you understand parametric
equations and how to eliminate the
parameter better subscribe to the
channel check out some of my past videos
and I'll see you in the next video I'll
talk to you soon